so I'm not you're probably thinking
right now you're thinking how is it that
a single-celled organism called a
prokaryote is able to navigate an
environment and avoid predation despite
having no nervous system and no brain to
speak of well the answer might have
something to do with something called
fashio so fashion is a type of
connective tissue that runs through an
entire organism not only supporting its
structures but potentially also acting
as a kind of communication system and
sensory organ in lieu of a nervous
system or an addition to a nervous
system it turns out that we have one of
these as well and by better
understanding how to use fashion and how
to keep it healthy we might be able to
boost our mobility our strength and our
general performance so stay tuned and in
this video I'm gonna explain exactly how
you might do that it's gonna be
fascinating his fur jur it's furture
he's for sure you know the Faja in my
video on tendon strength I explained
that it might not actually make sense to
think of individual muscles but though
we should rather consider them as muscle
tendon units the to work together to
such a degree there's more useful to
think of them as a single functioning
unit but perhaps it's folly to consider
any part of the muscular system in
isolation or the body for that matter
consider that your entire muscular
system is wrapped in the film like
substance called muscle fascia for many
years it has been largely ignored by the
fitness community thought of as the
inert stuff that was just there to fill
the gaps but if there's one thing we
should know about the human body is that
it doesn't waste space understanding the
muscle fascia and incorporating it into
your training might just be another
important tool for enhancing strength
increasing mobility boosting agility and
much more but there's also some
misunderstanding and hearsay surrounding
fascia so let's take a closer look to
recap then fashio is a brand or sheet of
connective tissue located beneath the
skin and made from collagen its role is
to separate stabilize and enclosed
muscles and organs there are actually
three layers of fashio those being the
superficial fascia deep fascia and
visceral fascia superficial fascia is
found just beneath the skin in the sub
cutis of most regions of the body
visceral faster suspends organs in there
cavities but the type we're most
interested in is the deep fascia which
surrounds the muscles bones nerve
and blood vessels it helps to divide
muscle groups into facial compartments
and contains a large amount of elastin
fiber to determine its elasticity most
specifically we're interested in muscle
faster or myofascial which is in turn a
type of deep fascia and thereby it can
store and return potential energy while
also influencing and perhaps limiting an
athlete's range of motion when you
sprint it's not just your muscles and
tendons that provide energy rebound then
but also your fashio particularly those
fatty tissues with tenderness or a pony
erotic properties when you stretch your
fashionista stretched to Basho is far
more than just a supportive springy wrap
though it also contains blood vessels
and sensory receptors in fact it's been
suggested that the fashion may be equal
or perhaps even superior to the retina
in terms of its density of sensory nerve
receptors it has between 6 to 10 times
more nerve endings than the muscle and
fashion also contains its own smooth
muscle cells which are thought to
contribute to facial contractility
in short healthy fashio could result in
greater physical strength more
explosiveness greater flexibility and
even improved balance and agility so how
do we go about getting their role on the
tennis ball right sort of so if you
already heard of the muscle fashion and
it's probably in the context of self
myofascial release this is the practice
of rolling on foam rollers and tennis
balls until it really hurts the thought
is that this can increase range of
motion without impairing muscle
performance or strength stretching
before workouts has recently been
demonstrated to potentially decrease
performance and increase the likelihood
of injury basically become wobbly but
increasing range of motion can surely be
helpful for movements like the squat so
if rolling on a ball can help to touch
your toes without robbing you of any of
your strength then that's definitely a
good thing indeed this has been shown to
be the case in several studies likewise
self myofascial release may be effective
in reducing chronic pain and has been
shown to aid recovery by reducing Dom's
when used after a workout if you want to
see the effects of massaging the fashio
for yourself then tried touching your
toes tricky right now take a tennis ball
and place it beneath the arch of your
right foot place some weight on that
foot and then really let it dig in there
now all it around a little making sure
you get the whole thing this should be a
little uncomfortable but not
searing agony now do the same thing on
your left
and now try touching your toes again if
our little experiment has worked these
should find Zika now touch your toes
more easily than you could before this
demonstration was popularized by
structural integration experts Tom Myers
and it sheds light on just how
incredibly connected the fashio is
houses massaging your foot affect the
tightness of your calves hamstrings and
glutes it comes down to the fact that
fashio is connected across your entire
body and according to Myers we can
separate our fashion into five major
chains with those being the superficial
backline superficial frontline lateral
line spiral line and deep front line the
superficial back line starts at the
bottom of the feet and continues all the
way over the top of the head ending at
the brow Ridge by loosening the
fashioner under your feet you actually
help to relax across the entire
posterior chain thereby increasing the
range of motion in a few seconds flat
others have suggested overt we really
only have one fashio it's also worth
noting as well that fashion can vary a
lot in terms of its thickness and its
composition depending on its location
but point is it's all very connected and
that's why rolling on one part of the
body can have effects across your entire
and that to me so far so good but the
bad news is that we currently don't have
much of an understanding of precisely
how this all works read a number of
popular blogs and they'll tell you that
it has to do with breaking up myofascial
adhesions the theory goes that scar
tissues form in the fashion over time
thanks to misuse and overuse resulting
in a change in facial architecture that
makes it rigid and tight by applying
pressure in these areas then it's
thought that we can break up that scar
tissue and help to regain normal
movement the only problem is that
there's zero evidence for this moreover
when you understand the fashion a little
bit better it becomes apparent that it's
highly unlikely that this is how the
whole thing works
after all those collagen fibers are
actually proportionately as strong as
steel and it's therefore very unlikely
that you'd be able to break down any
scar tissue or change the structure of
the fashio through force alone it
actually takes collagen about three
years to completely remodel as others
have pointed out if it were really that
easy to break up your fashio then you'd
do it all the time like when you're
sitting on your buttocks watching this
video for instance and applying far more
force over long periods then any bout of
foam rolling will accomplish then
there's the fact that the benefits of
frame rolling only appeared to be
temporary in nature the increased range
of motion where
after a while so your job in the gym is
to capitalize on that window of
opportunity to lay down new movement
patterns if that's the case though then
it seems unlikely that we're actually
changing the physical structure of the
fashio also if it was so easy to break
up scar tissue in the fashio wouldn't it
be quite dangerous to attempt this on
our own
wouldn't we risk damaging healthy fashio
and causing more harm than good
fortunately it appears that something
else is actually going on here while
this is still just a theory the more
likely explanation that's rising to
prominence at the moment is that foam
rolling and similar practices actually
help to temporarily relax tension in the
fashio rather than break it up in any
way remember your fashion Taine's muscle
fiber not to mention the carne receptors
that respond to touch books such as
relaxin to stretch show us the link
between relaxing the nervous system an
increasing range of motion basically
when we move beyond a certain safe point
the nervous system will kick in causing
tension to prevent us from injuring
ourselves it's even been suggested that
the fashio
may act as a communication system
carrying electrical signals between
muscle groups and nerve endings this
would further explain how relaxing the
fashion on the foot might help to ease
movement in the legs and I wonder if it
might also have something to do with
muscular irradiation the observation
that contracting one muscle will cause
others around it to contract in kind
basically the fascist seems able to
conduct electrical impulses so that
tensing or relaxing any muscle will
cause a kind of ripple effect across the
body this is another reason it's so
important to look after your fashio if
you don't then it will lead to
compensate or movement patterns that
could greatly increase your chances of
injury down the line something as
seemingly simple as tightness in the
foot could lead to tightness in the knee
which might lead you to squat badly and
hurt your back some massage therapists
now employ a technique called facial and
winding based on this concept applying
light pressure to sensitive areas in the
fashio
in order to trigger a relaxation of the
surrounding muscle it may also be that
facial release helped to somehow
override the pain mechanism thus
allowing us to increase range of motion
without the nervous system kicking in to
halt our movement much like PNF
stretching I actually suspect that there
are a lot of similarities between PNF
stretching and myofascial release and
that many studies focus on comparing
these two for those that don't know PNF
stretching is proprioceptive
neuromuscular facilitation this form of
stretching involves contracting the
muscles in a stretch
position and then relaxing them you can
learn more by checking out my video on
weighted stretching so what does this
teach us firstly don't be so keen to buy
into every new technique and explanation
offered by fitness blogs secondly the
best way to practice myofascial release
may actually be with a gentle relaxed
and targeted pressure don't target the
sites of pain but rather the surrounding
muscle tissue avoiding any bony areas
when you feel a kind of release then
that is where you want to work gently
deeper into the region avoid areas like
the lower spine and instead target
muscles that feel tight or restricted
popular choices include the calves
hamstrings glutes and quads I personally
have quite tight calves and I find that
my official release has greatly helped
me to increase my range of motion but
don't forget the upper body to do all
this at the start of your workouts and
then stretch at the end but this is
still somewhat theoretical like I say
and I wager that the fascia harbors yet
more secrets I actually also wonder
whether performing body scan meditation
could help to relieve tension in the
fashio and increase mobility improve
perception that way this form of
meditation involves focusing on each
part of the body in some versions
practitioners then begin contracting the
muscles in the region and then
consciously allowing them to completely
relax as much as possible this is useful
for getting into a state of relaxation
but perhaps it could also be useful to
release tension in the muscles and the
surrounding tissues try actively
relaxing your face right now and you'll
see how much tension there is even in
those small tiny muscles it's also just
a theory but maybe using this meditation
for 10 minutes prior to training could
help you to attack workouts with greater
focus
improve the mind body awareness and less
injury causing tension I'll be
experimenting with that and I'll get
back to you there are some other things
you can do right now to make more use of
your fresher one is to recognize that
your fashio works best when it's well
hydrated fasciae is moist to the touch
and when it dries out it can lose
flexibility and become more brittle
Moisture also helps the patch to glide
over other tissue rather than sticking
so keeping yourself well hydrated is as
ever really important what some more
important layers that you also need to
incorporate a range of different
movements into your training movement
helps to keep the water flowing to those
areas and might also help to keep the
micro vacuoles open it seems that a lack
of motion can cause the fashio to become
brittle and rigid in a specific region
so if you're just repeating the same
five movements in the
over and over this will contribute to
your loss of mobility and flexibility
keep your body guessing and adapting and
ideally get outside and start training
unpredictable terrain swing climb swim
trail run and you'll keep your fashion
limber perhaps even running barefoot or
using more minimal Footwear could help
to provide some benefit here training
with functional chaotic movements by
using your body weight using kettlebells
using old-time strongman lifts just
don't be predictable and machine like
and if you want to encourage the elastic
and explosive nature of fashio then
incorporate explosive plyometric
movements either way it's time to start
thinking of the body as a single
cohesive mechanism we're not a series of
joints and muscles our body is rather
one huge interconnected and highly
complex machine we need to start
treating it and moving it as such so I
hope you found this video useful and
interesting guys if you did then please
consider leaving a like that helps me
out immensely share it around that also
helps in fact one of the very best
things you can do for this channel is to
share my videos on reddit and places
like that
I hugely appreciate all your support all
your comments and your likes and your
shares and your comments and your
subscriptions they've all helped the
channel to grow immensely lately and I'm
hugely grateful I've got tons more on
the way on Fitness brain training
productivity all the usual stuff also
this week I have something really
special and different coming so keep
your eyes tuned to the chow
it's gonna be awesome so thanks a ton
for watching and I'll see you next time
bye for now